when I drew and when everyone true their
first parabola shape and we're going
drew it as a parabola I think and you
say look that's what a projector does
and I've thrown objects to the air for
my entire life it makes a parabola right
except in mathematics you have to be
careful or rather mathematics allows you
to be careful because it looks like a
parabola but who says it actually is now
we've seen lots of clues that it should
be but in mathematics we don't you know
satisfied with clues we want to proof we
want to be able to conclusively say yeah
absolutely doesn't just look like one it
absolutely is
so here's what I'm going to do give it
some kind of initial condition right now
by the way I'm just going to distinguish
usually we'd say like some velocity
lowercase V and some angle that aren't
flying through the air theater but these
are my initial conditions okay so just
to make this nice and neat run Econoline
V naught or that kind of thing I'm gonna
call it capital V for my angle of
projection sorry my my initial velocity
where I start and alpha because you know
first let up as my angle projection
where I begin now after all your
integration when you start for
acceleration you climb up through
velocity and to displacement you're
going to get these familiar equations
over here right so I'm gonna go V T cos
alpha this is my initial condition right
vs. here I get my minus 1/2 GT squared
can you remind me why that is the case
as time progresses what happens you get
more and more influence of gravity on my
object right until eventually it
overcomes however much initial velocity
you put in plus your VT sign up right
now do you remember we said we drew this
graph like that graph ok and we said you
know for normal displacement the
equations and and graphs would say well
look you want to think about time and
you want to compare that to displacement
but we said look we're in projectile
motion Landau right we've got two
dimensions and bushes to think about so
this is not going to cut it anymore I
need to be able to use my vertical axis
for their permission
we said we said this had better go back
to being wine and this had better be ex
okay which is kind of nice that's the
best way we think about but then the
problem is well what do we do with time
can't draw another time axis so people
with two disparate briefly what did we
say time was going to do what role did
it play in this arrangement
it's the parameter right it's this third
other variable but it's hiding behind
the other two variables and defines what
they are know when you get think back to
when you were doing like travelers and
even the unit circle that kind of thing
a natural thing to do when you've got a
parameter is to try and eliminate it
right rather than having two parametric
equations wouldn't it be nicer if I just
had a single equation which related what
these two variables are so what you want
to do such a thing when you want to
eliminate a parameter and you've got two
equations what do you do yeah you want
to do some kind of rearrangement so you
can substitute and get rid of well in
this case the parameter is T so which of
these equations do you think would be
easier to rearrange so that you can
eliminate it clear the first one right
so all I need to do I just need to make
T the subjects which means on both sides
I'm going to divide through by V cos
alpha right so that'll give me this okay
now given that all I have to do is take
that substitute into Y and see what
happens now this is a result not to be
memorized but we want to notice some
interesting things about and see how it
can be applied okay so firstly let's
just do the substitution shall we
this is going to be y equals minus 1/2 G
this T right so this is gonna be X V
squared let's just finish this up take
away V here's my thing again write X on
yeah yeah yeah because up
and then I'm going to Sai Natha that was
already hanging there from the initial
point right now all I want to do I don't
want to do too much me possession with
this
I just want to tidy up a tiny a little
bit firstly I noticed G V and alpha
right number one the B's cancel their
number two G and V because after which
are left behind they're all constants
all constants right so I'm going to tidy
this up just a tiny little bit here you
can see I'm gonna get - I'm just gonna
put the G on the top actually on two V
squared cos squared alpha
do you agree that's my coefficient and
then what's actually very is x squared
do you grow that over here being my B's
cancel what do I get left with is the
coefficient the coefficient the closet
is just 10 alpha right that's the thing
that's actually just whatever you're
given out please don't get a date that
times X so you look at this this is a
quadratic in X right and so yeah it
doesn't just look like a parabola it
actually is once you sit down you
evaluate you get some numbers up now
that's the first thing I wanna point out
yeah it doesn't just look like a
parabola it is finally the nice thing
about this is if I know what this
equation is baby come on we're in
calculus limit right and the natural
thing to do any person like this is the
differentiator now why would it be
useful to differentiate it firstly what
is the trivial to comes out the front
and cancel
I'm differentiating not integrated I
cannot just to finish right what is this
thing this is the gradient given any
particular value X now Y is grading
useful to us in projectile motion and
it's because it gives us it gives us any
angle you want any angle you want this M
this gradient is tan theta not 10 alpha
alpha is an initial condition copy good
flight
ten feet up whatever angle you like it a
draw sir mom draw some particular moment
in time in this one that one or the
initial condition right you want to find
your angle of inclination at any
particular time just use the gradient
because what this tells you is the
equation of the projectiles path through
the air right without respect to time I
didn't care what what time you are we
call this the equation Oh pop what is it
they actually doing through the air